so this soluble versus insoluble silicon
thing it doesn't make a lot of sense
from a scientific point of view and
there are just a lot of points here to
break down first off it doesn't matter
if a conditioning ingredient is soluble
or not you don't need to wash out all of
your conditioner conditioners don't form
a continuous film on your hair it's more
sort of like little blobs so it's not
like blocking stuff going in or out of
hair it can just stay there it's like a
protective paint on a drink bottle or
something you don't have to scrub off
all the paint every time and apply new
paint secondly things that don't
dissolve in water wash off hair all of
the time oils for example aren't water
soluble that is the whole point of
having surfactant and shampoos they have
the long Wiggly bit which can dissolve
things that aren't water soluble on top
of that water soluble doesn't mean it
necessarily comes off hair easily hair
is really good at hydrogen bonding and
so is water and that's actually how a
lot of ingredients dissolve in water but
that also means that things that
dissolve in water sometimes can stick to
hair too well so some of the most sticky
Hair Care ingredients that build up on
hair are actually charged ingredients
that are relatively water soluble